puisque c'est fermé la médiathèque bah
je te propose d'aller au parcours santé
s'installer sur un banc à l'ombre et
puis faire l'entretien à ce moment-là
ce soir on sera mieux
quel est ton vœu numéro 1
en terme de discipline et aujourd'hui
donc on reçoit une candidate au
bénévolat sur sur les Jeux des îles
notamment sur les le poste de
responsable de site j'avais le choix
entre hôtesse steward chauffeur ou
responsable de site donc ils ont coché
parole d'importance on a donc convoqué
ceux qui voulaient être responsables de
sites j'en ai reçu 36 ans deux jours
le sport fait partie de ma vie j'ai été
militaire plus de 16 ans j'ai eu la
chance de faire des sports d'hiver et
variés avoir la chance de avec mon petit
vécu on va dire dans le passé associatif
sportif
de découvrir du monde de discuter avec
des gens d'avoir des échanges dans ce
domaine que j'aime plus particulièrement
qui est le sport bon actuellement je
fais plus du tennis puisque ici
voilà mais pour moi oui c'est un bonheur
que c'est juste déroule chez nous et de
pouvoir donner un petit peu de temps
ça montre que un engouement vraiment
pour le bénévolat à la Réunion qui est
extraordinaire quoi ça fait vraiment
vraiment plaisir et ça conforte le
bénévole que je suis sur certaines
valeurs on a souvent les gros titres des
journaux sur des gens qui
vont piquer dans la caisse ou vont avoir
un comportement pas tout à fait
exemplaire et on ne parle jamais
finalement ou rarement de ceux qui sont
les besogneux du monde associatif et
sportifs réunionnais en même temps c'est
des gens qui sont demandeurs de rien ni
de célébrités encore moins alors ça
c'est quelque chose qui va surpris aussi
c'est que personne ne m'a parlé d'un
éventuel défraiement ou d'un avantage
quelconque à faire ça dans un monde où
tout se vend tout s'achète voir ça c'est
ça rebooste le bénévole que je suis ça
c'est clair donc j'invite tout le monde
à venir participer de venir voir et
surtout de venir à la cérémonie
d'ouverture de ces jeux Karine merci à
très bientôt